so tell us first of all about the makeup
on the Hulk or the makeup you know funny
it took three and a half hours four
hours to put on but the hardest thing is
do and do it and make up a highly
retouched all day long it would go off
for like maybe 12 or 14 hours how's it
feel and all that makeup as well it's so
horrible
I mean want to make up were completed I
love the carrot the carrot is beautiful
but very uncomfortable because the
clothes the cause a lot of time I had to
be situated in a motor home with the air
condition of my face these suffer for
your art then oh yeah some time want to
be the hope now we will love the Hulk
obviously but why do you think we all
love the whole the sensitivity because
everyone of art has a little hop inside
of us and we can angry we relate to the
hospital to death you relate our
frustration I think we want to do the
help desert thousand Hawk my whole life
and a lot of anger a lot of diamond so I
was released out at the Hawk but that's
why in real life was a great transition
what is it about the original Hulk's you
think that makes it stand out so much
and what do you think of CGI yourself it
was a sensitivity and you can't compare
CG CG right with the human heart it was
a sensitivity to warm and the connection
is children love it because they can
feel that I had to use the bigger than
power as well as obviously the TV series
that we loved you for you're involved
when the latest film as well weren't you
Avengers Assemble you had your voice in
there what was that like being part of
that it was a huge production wasn't it
well it's really a million dollar
production they're very happy to have my
voice because you know for watching for
me the hope won't be around today they
were happy maybe part of their history
because you know the hawk wouldn't be
the same without my voice because I know
how the whole thing to feel where do you
summon that Hulk's voice from
my own frustration my own my private
rage well that fits doesn't it cuz
that's the character I will know that
today though yeah don't get angry good
idea
what did you think about the actors who
played the Hulk over the years in the
films for example I think the group of
Hoffa would be the last choice a plain
David Banner because we had Eric Bana
that we had every north and now we have
Mark Ruffalo I think marks the great
actor long as that you say you just
stayed with the character would you like
to see Mark Ruffalo do a Hulk movie
separate from the Avengers movies
because it was a lot of good word they
are doing our movie I think after the
next adventure because the reason is
because the Hawks the last movie the
adventure stays a day with the star in
the movie so definitely agreed to do a
Hawk movies I think that we done after
the adventure the second one will you be
involved in that do you think in any way
would you like to be oh yeah I love to
be with the characters an affair sure
would you like to do maybe something not
not like a hawk maybe was something but
I could play something again tight like
a general something now what have you
been up to lately that's what you want
to know - well I'm a movie coming out
called The Liberator is about an Asian
superheroes about a guy that rejected
from the military and you've decided to
write a book that did to expose the
truth and to kill him so in fact it has
superhero powers he's like an Asian
superhero I knew if you got a word for
your fans out there who are watching
this interview what would you like to
say to them I would like to say be nice
to yourself be nice to everyone and keep
supporting the character of the Hulk or
the other stupid here because that's to
make the world happy play
you